here in this video we shall ponder about
something a little bit out of the box
yet well within the comparison niche so
what if the original godzilla and the
original kong for each other that is
without including the later incarnations
and even adding extra weapons our
abilities to level any kind of playing
field the eighth wonder of the world
kong from the 1933 movie versus the
nuclear monster godzilla from the 1954
movie king kong vs gojira but before we
continue do click that subscribe button
to be a part of our mind cue family now
let's get down to business
let's start with the story of the
original king kong the original kong was
a giant ape the last member of his
species unlike the latter film skong's
origins remains relatively obscure and
still a mystery in this one kong had the
appearance of a normal gorilla but he
was considerably larger and stronger
reaching a height of around 24 feet kong
walked like a man and did not move
around like a gorilla
he possessed enormous canines and
protruded from his mouth outside of his
mouth giving him a far more bastille
appearance than any of his later
portrayals
with a thickly forward bra he also
looked angry
unlike his later depictions this
incarnation of kong was quite
simple-minded and his main enemy was a
large tyrannosaurus rex
now coming to godzilla the shodar goji
design is the name given to the kaiju
from the 1954 movie the lower body was
hefty the arms were little and the head
was huge and round the eyes were totally
round with tiny pupils and the face had
a
pair of prominent brows it also had
fangs photos a rough underside for the
tail and sharp tail tip and also
staggered rows of dorsal plates that
were you know his main attribute and it
was unique to it and a 1955 incarnation
i mean the designs on the shouldai goji
the dorsal plates had a dynamic design
and were one of a kind
godzilla was created by the atomic
bombings and nuclear testing in the
pacific its main enemy was humanity
itself and its height was 50 meters or
164 feet and has a very tough and
durable skin and also he has a power
called the atomic breath so if we
compare both these monsters side by side
we do have quite a disparity although
king kong was the king of his island he
was still captured by humans and taken
to new york city where he broke loose
and was ultimately killed by machine gun
fire from world war one era aircrafts on
the other hand godzilla was also killed
by humans in his first movie but he was
able to dish out with the entire
military and not even feeling a niche
against tank fire and missiles he was
killed however with an experimental
unique new weapon called the oxygen
destroyer so both these monsters fell
against humanity but
what would be like if they fought each
other
godzilla obviously has the size and
power advantage his 164 feet height
advantage against kong is completely off
the charts that would mean that he is as
tall as seven gongs one on top of
another i don't really think that gong
even with his powerful punches and
strong grip that took down a large t-rex
would be able to put up a fight against
godzilla who melts tanks and destroys
buildings just by his atomic breath
godzilla vs com of this year and in 1962
tried to even the scales by increasing
kong's size to be able to look at
godzilla face to face
but here it isn't so so the 1954 gojira
would just squash kong like a bug and
his size would be too much even for kong
to use uses
let's say his higher intellect to figure
out how to take the big monster down so
godzilla for the win
so anyway this was fun
the big g takes the prize for the
originals fight do you remember to leave
a like for support and subscribe to be a
part of our minecube family and most of
all ring that bell button for regular
updates on new monster content
right here on this channel till the next
one
take care fam